[Music]
wish upon me blood in my dog and I can't
see I'm trying to be what I'm destined
to be and nigg trying to take my life
away put a hole in a [__] for [__]
with me my back on the wall now you
going to see better watch how you talk
when you talk about me cuz I come and
take your life away
many many many many
many wish there me I don't cry no don't
look to the no mercy on [__] [__] put
money on my head go get refund
[__] I ain't dead I'm the
diamond in the dirt that a been I'm the
underr king and I a been Crown when I
round something special happen every
time I'm the greatest something like Ali
in this Prime I walk the block with the
bundles I've been KN The Humble swing
the when i r show you